on va revenir quelques mois en arrière
steven spielberg exprès des festivals
qui annonce palme d'or pour adel abdel
il ya finalement c'est vrai que c'est
jamais vu dans le cas du festival de
cannes cette palme d'or qui va un film
un réalisateur il ya deux comédiennes
l'art rapidement il ya quoi quand où et
quand on entend son prénom comme ça
c'est une sensation hallucinante en son
coeur qui s'arrêtent de battre au
contraire qui tout d'un coup il ya
tachycardie comment comment ça se passe
non il bat très fort mais c'est vrai
qu'au début
spielberg il s'est levé but et dans une
certaine émotion il a dit trois artistes
du coup j'étais un peu perdue je me suis
dit mais je comprends pas il ya trois
films ya trois axes a de quoi on parle
et là quand tu entends ton prénom battu
tu comprends et encore j'ai pas tout de
suite compris que c'était une palme
collectives mais aussi individuelles
mais non c'est énorme d'être face à des
gens qui ont bercé son enfance avec leur
cinéma et et qui sont en face de toi et
uma thurman qui trouva un prix c'est moi
je réalise toujours pas c'est quand on
parle de la panne que je me dis mais
on l'a eue que que je me dis pas
tous les jours j'ai la palme d'or parce
que pour moi c'était jamais j'ai osé
penser que que ça pouvait m'arriver
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup aux jurys
déjà c'était tellement une énorme fierté
mettre à côté de tous ces films
merci pourquoi de m'avoir donné ma
chance de faire partie de l'aventuré
mais
méravilles rencontrer mais c'est très
gentil de l'aider à avoir de philosophie
zen